[Music]
alright kids while we're waiting for the
audience to gather man just a little bit
of Restatement of information that's
been on there out online I put it down
on Instagram the other day have you ever
wanted to buy weed from Jay and Silent
Bob I know I have fictional characters
or not man the price has got to be good
so after all this time 25 years making
these movies and stuff we got this
chainsaw Bob reboot movie coming out in
that movie Jane saw Bob create three
strains of weed snowgoons smoochie
booties and berserker so in real life I
was like man we got to make this happen
we got it like in this best of all
possible worth how can we not [ __ ]
make this fake weed happen in the real
world so I don't from being a fake weed
dealer in movies to a real weed dealer
in real life how could I do that and
I'll show you how it happened man caviar
Mike's son that's caviar Mike right
there caviar Mike makes the best weed in
the world this stuff caviar man it is
tell them tell them man tell them what
it is weed in the world absolute best we
know what why well one because we put
the most cannabinoids can be in a
pre-roll possible and also we raised the
terpenes up to another level that
nobody's ever even thought mmm coming
back to me I've been smoking this weed
catch your phone I've been smoking this
weed this is the weed that powered me
all through Jay and Silent Bob rebooting
stuff this is the weed that stoner
smoked to get stoned my friends and so
me and Mike and Phil done last remember
it like a couple months ago I did the
cabbie challenge and lash says I'm gonna
introduce you to Mike he did introduce
me to Mike manse me my gods target what
can we do Mike said we can create that
weed so powered by caviar gold now we're
introducing that weed into the real
world snowgoons smoochie boo cheese and
berserker and we're having a signing
once I guess it is to signing we're
appearing me and J add herbarium on
Friday the 27th is right down the street
from my house sound LaBrea right in your
target and stuff is it we would Spencer
eat the best dispensary is where I go
get my stuff and that's where we're
gonna introduce
our brand-new three strains but I'm
gonna show you what it looks like and
then we're gonna show you the golden
ticket because if you come to the
signing and you buy one of our three
rolls you could wind up with a golden
ticket Mike's gonna explain Mike take
them into this let's show my pre-rolls
first basically when you get a pre-roll
it's gonna have we just stick a pig in
and twist there you go son you knows
comic strip look at that Berserker J man
this is fun Mike Mike had an idea caught
me up one day hold on bump back to me
Mike called me up one day goes hey man
like what if we include a little comic
strip in every pre-roll I said you and
genius man like Berserker like Bazooka
Joe and he said yeah like the Berserker
Jackson done so I wrote 10 different
little comic strips and we had Steve
stark draw them up so every time you buy
a pre-roll you get a little comic strip
and as well but here's the big news man
ready tell them Mike one of the tickets
is gonna be the golden ticket and that's
where you win $1,000 $1,000 that's right
thousand dollars cash man show them what
it looks like whoo right there you could
try to copy it but don't worry man this
one's gonna be signed by me and Mike so
they'll only be two - right - right now
in the whole world man but we're gonna
have it on Friday so if you're buying
weed on Friday if you're buying the
pre-rolls like there's the there's our
snooty boo cheese that's the sativa
is bright and tasty as a morning joint
it tastes like maple syrup is over to
you it will be the super Steve it'll be
the official joint of Canada when it
gets up there cuz it tastes like Canada
then show them the hybrid look at that
there's a hybrid sprinting around so
they can see it's James Bond but
presents Berserker and then powered by
caviar Gold Sun and then show them the
last one
snoo guns that's our indica and tell
them how powerful it is it's about 60%
and we're from 40 to 60 percent THC and
about 5% CBD oh good lord now if you
like hey man those are pretty rolls I
like to buy mine ugh and I like to grind
it myself well
look at this look at what Mike's doing
right there man he's reaching into a box
of our lunar modules and oh yeah oh I
could smell it man oh it's amazing he
can you smell it right to the camera
yeah so look man there's three boxes of
different there's the snowgoons lunar
modules the berserker lunar modules the
snooty bujji's lunar modules man so kind
of like was it cut moon rocks this is
the this is the the Jay and Silent Bob
version moon rocks lunar modules man so
you come to the signing
you could buy weed from Jay and Silent
Bob you buy three each one of the pre
rolls and we take you can take a picture
with us we'll selfie it up with the end
stuff like that but somebody gonna buy
one of them pre-rolls
open it up look for their little comic
strip like this and thinking they're
gonna pull this out and they'd be happy
with this and look if you put ten of
these together man I'll collect all ten
you bring it to any place that sells yes
are we they'll give you a free pre-roll
and stuff but you're gonna be looking
for this and you're gonna wind up
opening this you're gonna be like a
thousand dollars I know what I'm gonna
spend it on caviar Gold Sun somebody
online asked me the other day they said
in that stuff like 50 bucks of joint I
said no man is 30 bucks drawn butter
smokes like 100 bucks a joint man this
is incredible weed Mike's been doing for
how long tell him how long you been to
space 10 years 10 years you've been
working on him perfecting his craft man
patent pending patent pending how many
countries 163 oh my lord he's gonna be a
magnate he's a weed magnate now he's
gonna take on the [ __ ] world man and
look he let me in he put me in with that
step right there our own [ __ ] brands
there it is so now we're gonna sign the
golden ticket man we're gonna watch his
sign it last you're gonna take the
camera from me I'll spin it around go
ahead man this is legit they could win
serious money honey we're gonna sign on
the back yeah smart smart here we go
there's one you saw that - Bam Bam
cash money man
people really been with caviar gold you
know what I'm saying look at him signing
away man that's a man who believes in
his business he knows he's got the right
product dude people been
they've been tasting this or any in
advance at other dispensaries you've
been giving them out in the state or no
not really another dispensary just in
our in-house kitchens we uh and people
been feeling it freaking out I can't
wait to take this man we're gonna jump
on like I'm gonna be on be real show
it's talking to be real and we're gonna
smoke this man and see if it does to him
what it does to everyone else this
stuff's amazing so Friday the 27th this
Friday you come down to her barians
right on La Brea right by Target man bye
big target Plaza come on in 420 it
begins smooch and me and J are gonna be
there
you buy three pre-rolls take a picture
with this man sit around chitchat and
whatnot we're gonna be doing until
closing and then you will be the first
to enjoy this amazing wheat look at look
at this man look at the design and the
care that's been put into this it's
amazing man and there's that symbol that
means quality man caviar gold so come on
out on Friday take some pics buy some
weed it's a smoked out man buy your weed
from Jay and Silent Bob and when you do
that you're gonna both fact this man
here Mike we thank you for the greatest
world in the world greatest weed in the
world man my love all right there it is
folks come down to herbarium on Friday
for them for the for the premiere the
world premiere of our strains of weed
man we'll see you there it's gonna be a
smokin good time wink
you